Traduttore: Nadia Paladini
Revisore: Angela Dettori
Salve a tutti.
Vi racconterò oggi di come,
partendo da Perugia,
abbiamo portato la scienza
nei musei europei
studiando centinaia di opere d'arte
per svelarne i segreti
contenuti all'interno della materia.
Quando vediamo un oggetto d'arte
dobbiamo pensare
che è un miscuglio
incredibile e specialissimo
di composti chimici, di materiali,
materiali che sono stati manipolati
prima dall'artista,
ma poi anche, lentamente, dal tempo,
e che riescono a rappresentare l'immagine,
l'idea dell'artista adesso,
e la trasmetteranno nel futuro.
Quindi, se pensate alla potenza
di un lavoro interdisciplinare
dove, insieme allo storico dell'arte,
al restauratore e all'archeologo,
c'è anche uno scienziato dei materiali,
questo dà la possibilità
di svelare segreti inaspettati
sul metodo di creazione
di un'opera d'arte da parte dell'artista,
ma anche sulla storia dell'oggetto
nel tempo e, non meno importante,
sulla conservazione di questo oggetto.
Vediamo un esempio
di questo connubio tra arte e scienza.
Nel dipinto che vedete, in verde,
— è un Prato fiorito di Vincent Van Gogh,
dipinto nel 1887 —
una radiografia in passato
aveva rivelato un volto.
Questo volto, oggi,
grazie a misure a luce di sincrotrone
è stato dettagliato in modo magnifico,
ne vediamo addirittura il colore,
le fattezze: è un volto sottostante
il dipinto principale.
E adesso che lo vediamo così bene capiamo
che è un volto in realtà noto,
simile ad altri dipinti
di Vincent Van Gogh.
Quindi la storia del dipinto è svelata:
fu realizzato in Olanda
in un periodo precedente,
probabilmente intorno al 1885,
portato da Vincent Van Gogh a Parigi
e lì riutilizzato
per poi eseguire questo Prato fiorito,
molto più in linea con la moda parigina.
Allora questi connubi felici arte-scienza
dove sveliamo misteri,
dove scopriamo nuovi dipinti,
ci sono, ma purtroppo non sono tanti,
e il motivo è presto detto.
Vediamo cosa è successo a questo dipinto
per avere questo mistero svelato.
È stato innanzitutto portato
per 400 chilometri da Otterlo,
dove è conservato, ad Amburgo,
a un laboratorio di luce di sincrotrone.
Bene, il trasporto di un'opera,
ve lo immaginate,
è sempre un'operazione pericolosa,
non gradita, nonché molto costosa.
Altro fatto è che il dipinto
è stato campionato, alcuni frammenti
— millimetrici, ma frammenti originali
di materia di Van Gogh —
sono stati presi con un bisturi
e portati in un altro laboratorio
di luce di sincrotrone a Grenoble.
Bene, quindi questo che potrebbe essere
un felice connubio
poi si arena di fronte al fatto
che la scienza dei materiali
propone metodi non idonei, non adatti,
e quindi lo storico dell'arte,
il restauratore
spesso preferisce rimanere cieco,
non avere informazioni sui materiali
piuttosto che trasportare l'opera
o addirittura campionarla.
Allora abbiamo la necessità
di un'innovazione.
Quale può essere l'innovazione?
L'idea sarebbe quella
di adattare questi metodi scientifici
alla peculiarità del settore
e, a partire dagli anni 2000,
nel mio centro di ricerca,
CNR e università,
abbiamo pensato
di ribaltare la prospettiva:
se l'opera d'arte
non può viaggiare in laboratorio,
che sia il laboratorio
che allora si adatta
e viaggia e va all'opera.
Quindi abbiamo iniziato a realizzare,
prototipare, adattare
una serie di strumentazioni
che qui vi mostro,
che riuscissero a fare questo lavoro nuovo
e abbiamo utilizzato sempre spettroscopia,
quindi interazione luce-materia.
Sono una serie di strumentazioni
che ci permettono
di avere la composizione delle molecole
sulla superficie di questi oggetti
in modo non invasivo.
Le strumentazioni sono disassemblabili
e le mettiamo in queste casse.
Sembrano un po' le casse dei musicisti,
ma in realtà noi invece
di chitarra elettrica o sintetizzatore
abbiamo una serie di detector,
laser pulsati a varia energia, e così via.
La nostra tournée si realizza
viaggiando comodamente
con questo transporter
che qui vedete parcheggiato
davanti al Museo di Picasso ad Antibes,
un posto bellissimo.
Allora vi faccio vedere un esempio
di come, nella pratica,
questo laboratorio mobile,
che chiama "Molab", lavora.
È un documentario
che filma il nostro arrivo a Venezia,
alla Peggy Guggenheim Collection,
dove siamo stati invitati
o chiamati a studiare 11 dipinti
di Jackson Pollock.
Lo conoscete — è il pittore
"genio e sregolatezza" americano,
un pioniere dell'arte contemporanea,
che ha inventato una tecnica,
quella del dripping.
È morto a 44 anni per incidente stradale,
è un po' considerato il James Dean
dell'arte contemporanea.
Insomma, il Molab parte,
in questo caso è science on the boat.
Andiamo con le nostre casse
con gli strumenti scientifici
sul Canal Grande,
arriviamo a Palazzo Venier dei Leoni,
dove si trova questa magnifica collezione
di Peggy Guggenheim.
Le scatole vengono portate nel museo
e dopo poche ore, come per magia,
c'è un laboratorio
di spettroscopia avanzata
nelle sale di esibizione del museo,
che lavora con i materiali di Pollock.
Lavoriamo sempre, se possibile,
in presenza del pubblico,
che in genere è molto incuriosito
e vede quello che sta andando avanti
nelle sale del museo;
e anche sempre in collaborazione
col conservatore,
che in questo caso è Luciano Pensabene,
che insieme a noi decide
dove andare a eseguire le misure.
Questo che vedete è un fotogramma
che ci fa vedere la complicazione,
il mistero della materia usata da Pollock.
È il fotogramma di un quadro molto grande
che è l'icona dell'arte
del ventesimo secolo
e si chiama Alchemy
— Alchimia, appunto.
Sono 2 metri e 40
per 1 metro e 40 di caos materico,
come potete vedere,
ma è un caos, diciamo, controllato.
I materiali e lo studio dei materiali
che cosa ci hanno insegnato?
Abbiamo eseguito oltre 300 punti,
una quantità di misure impensabili
con un campionamento,
— pensate che questo quadro
vale più di 150 milioni di dollari —
e che cosa si fa?
Abbiamo scoperto che i materiali
utilizzati da Pollock non sono casuali:
lui, ad esempio, usa 12 colori,
oltre il silver e il black.
Ma non sono 12 colori qualunque,
sono accoppiati,
e ad esempio per il rosso
c'è un solfuro di cadmio e selenio
e una toluidina red;
questi due, che a occhio
sembrano identici,
in realtà permettono
di avere diverse proprietà fisiche
in termini di opacità
e fluidità del colore.
In modo simile,
Pollock utilizza qui, per la prima volta,
— e Alchimia è il primo quadro
che lui non esegue sul cavalletto,
bensì per terra schizzando il colore —
usa per la prima volta
una resina di sintesi, alchidica,
che non era materiale d'artista,
lui probabilmente la trova in ferramenta,
era prodotta negli anni '40
e usata in commercio
per dipingere termosifoni, auto e altro.
Perché la sceglie?
Perché la resina alchidica,
rispetto a un olio tradizionale
o un polimero per artisti,
ha molta più fluidità per fare il gesto,
e al contempo velocità di polimerizzazione
per bloccare questo gesto
sulla superficie.
Allora Pollock, che noi immaginiamo
tutto genio e sregolatezza,
in realtà, nella pittura,
è un precisissimo
conoscitore dei materiali,
che seleziona per quello che vuole fare.
Questi dati, al contempo,
servono anche per il restauro.
Alchemy non era stata mai restaurata prima
proprio per la difficoltà del restauratore
di andare a operare con solventi
in una materia incognita e imprevedibile
come quella dell'arte contemporanea.
Bene. Dopo i primi successi italiani
il Molab debutta in Europa
e debutta — devo dire —
all'inizio, con grosso scetticismo
da parte dei colleghi scienziati
che non ritenevano che potessimo
avere buoni risultati scientifici
lavorando addirittura in un museo,
in un sito archeologico, posti strani,
con strumentazioni portatili.
In realtà poi, al contempo,
siamo stati accolti con grande entusiasmo
dall'altra parte
di questo studio multidisciplinare
perché i restauratori, i conservatori
e gli storici dell'arte han detto:
"Bene! finalmente una scienza amica
che arriva da noi, dove c'è bisogno!"
E anche i risultati scientifici
sono arrivati presto.
Questa che vedete è una pagina
di codici precolombiani.
Sono oggetti meravigliosi
e raccontano con dei pittogrammi
la religione, i calendari,
l'astronomia, la politica
delle popolazioni mesoamericane.
Il guaio è che, purtroppo,
abbiamo solo 16 di questi codici
in tutto il mondo
perché sono stati distrutti
dai conquistatori spagnoli,
e questi 16 sopravvissuti sono in Europa,
perché furono spediti
come regali naïf
particolari ai regnanti
che stavano finanziando la spedizione.
Quindi tutta la conoscenza
della cultura mesoamericana
è racchiusa in questi codici,
che ci narrano proprio la vita,
la religione e la politica.
Sono in Europa e nessuno
li aveva mai studiati prima,
—potete immaginare:
non si possono spostare né campionare —
finché non c'è stata la possibilità
di studiarli con il Molab.
Sono conservati, ad esempio,
qui a Roma, alla Biblioteca Vaticana,
al Museo Antropologico di Madrid,
al British Museum di Londra
e alla Bodleian University [Library]
di Oxford.
Bene, ne abbiamo studiati
non tutti e 16, ma parecchi,
e abbiamo osservato qualcosa di peculiare.
Questi colori che vedete
così brillanti, belli,
usati dagli scriba
per realizzare i pittogrammi
hanno una peculiarità:
sono tutti, o per lo più,
colori estratti da fiori.
Quindi il fiore veniva macerato in acqua,
veniva estratto il colorante,
poi veniva adsorbito su argilla
e così dipinto.
Questo utilizzo peculiare dei fiori
in modo così esteso, che non è tipico
di altre espressioni artistiche
delle popolazioni mesoamericane,
viene messo in riferimento
a quella che conosciamo essere
la rappresentazione della poesia
per la popolazione,
che è "parlare fiorito"
o "cantare fiorito",
e questi codici, in effetti,
venivano declamati alle popolazioni
per esprimere proprio
la religione, la politica,
e quindi è una sorta di materializzazione
dell'idea stessa dell'oggetto artistico.
Bene. Vi dicevo,
la bellezza di queste misure
è anche quella di determinare
lo stato di conservazione.
Questo è il caso del giallo di Van Gogh
dei Girasoli.
Il giallo di Van Gogh dei Girasoli,
un quadro notissimo, amatissimo,
è un giallo di cromo che ha purtroppo
la tendenza a virare nel tempo.
Ella Hendriks si è accorta
di questo problema
— è conservatrice al Van Gogh Museum —
ha ritirato il dipinto dall'esposizione
e che cos'ha fatto?
Ha chiamato il Molab per analizzarlo.
Siamo andati con le nostre strumentazioni,
abbiamo anche studiato in laboratorio
il processo di degrado,
che è una fotoriduzione,
e abbiamo scoperto
che c'è una tipologia di giallo di cromo
che tende a inscurirsi e un'altra no,
infine abbiamo dato
una mappatura di tutto il dipinto
per capire esattamente
qual è lo stato di conservazione,
in quali zone dobbiamo porre attenzione
e come illuminare
e far tornare il dipinto sicuro
in esposizione per il pubblico.
Bene, questo è il Molab:
il Molab lavora e porta la scienza,
ma anche gli scienziati, on the road.
Negli ultimi 10 anni
siamo stati finanziati
dalla Commissione Europea
come prima e unica infrastruttura mobile
per i beni culturali.
Grazie a questo
abbiamo potuto visitare decine di paesi,
invitati da musei,
siti archeologici, chiese.
È stato decisamente un successo
oltre le nostre stesse aspettative
e se penso a quando, nel 2000,
abbiamo avuto quest'idea,
non avremmo di certo immaginato
che oggi altri avrebbero
seguito le nostre orme.
Ci sono ora altri laboratori
in Italia e in Europa
che stanno facendo questo tipo di misure.
Nell'insieme, un approccio non invasivo
ha davvero portato un grande impulso
alla scienza dei beni culturali,
sia in termini di quantità
di oggetti studiati,
— altrimenti non lo sarebbero stati —
ma anche in termini di qualità
della ricerca prodotta.
E perché questa qualità è aumentata?
Perché le strumentazioni sono buone,
hanno buone performance,
ma soprattutto perché
queste strumentazioni portatili
facilitano l'interdisciplinarità,
ci portano insieme nello stesso luogo
e nello stesso tempo
con scienziati di discipline diverse,
storici dell'arte e restauratori,
in empatia di fronte all'opera.
Questo è il segreto del Molab
e questo pensiamo sia il segreto
anche di altre tecnologie e scienze
quando si applicano
ad ambiti interdisciplinari.
Grazie.
(Applausi)